le premier ministre n'a philippe
couillard est arrivé à la tête du
gouvernement il ya tout juste deux mois
sa première session parlementaire a été
courte mais intense et cette semaine
l'évasion de trois détenus au centre de
détention de québec à la prison
d'orsainville comme on l'appelle a mis
le gouvernement un coup iard à l'épreuve
mais retient de biron on nous fait le
bilan de la session
une dernière semaine pénible pour le
gouvernement empêtré dans ses
déclarations à la suite de l'évasion de
trois prévenus à québec l'opposition a
réclamé la tête de la ministre de la
sécurité publique le premier ministre a
plutôt vanter ses talents énergie
courageuse et compétente elle a donc
toute la confiance du premier ministre
du gouvernement et de ses collègues
l'assemblée nationale
laissant entendre que le gouvernement a
finalement repris le dessus monsieur
barrette la pinière après l'adoption de
son premier budget pour 62 contre 44
abstentions aucune le premier ministre
est passé à son bilan de session où il a
dû défendre ses ministres à nouveau ça a
ajouté un élément de controverses à la
fin de la session c'est clair mais ça ne
change pas la destination du
gouvernement la destination du
gouvernement qui s'appuie sur le constat
des finances publiques demain parce
qu'on connaît la courte session de
quatre semaines aura surtout permis au
gouvernement de mettre la table pour les
décisions difficiles qui s'annoncent
qu'on est rendu au fameux mur et même
dépasser un peu le fameux promesses
brisées moi c'est ce que je retiens de
l'action gouvernementale
il parle notamment des investissements
promis dans les infrastructures le pq
dénonce ou si la décision du
gouvernement de mettre en place deux
commissions pour réviser la fiscalité et
les programmes c'est quand même assez
incroyable qu'on sous traite une
responsabilité aussi importante c'est un
gouvernement qui ne sait pas où est ce
qu'il s'en va alors qu'as tu ne sais pas
ce que tu ta voix qu'est ce que vous
pensez qu'on fait en confiant comme tu
es d'un élu mais la cac elle apprécie
les intentions austère des libéraux
monde gérait 5 sur 10 il lui donne zéro
pour ces mesures de relance économique
mais dix sur dix pour le ménage qu'il
promet de faire poitrine livrer la
marchandise aussi offert patat c'est à
l'automne que les intentions du
gouvernement
deviendront de plus en plus concrète et
la grogne n'est pas très loin le projet
de loi sur les régimes de retraite a
déjà été reçue par les syndicats par une
déclaration guerre ici martin biron
radio canada québec